luxurious
[Music]
hello hello hello me and my nine other
friends who are also medical students
are going to stay in a villa and it is
completely paid by our medical school
love you hey how are you feeling about
going to the villa
we're not going back
yeah jacuzzi
[Music]
extensions oh my God I'm excited here
[Music]
it's lovely yeah
[Music]
[Music]
they gave us fortune cookies so cute
Jack do you want to show us your room
welcome to the master bedroom we have a
lovely Skyline to fall asleep with
little stars and a bathtub in the middle
of the room look at that look at that
looks
up with the viewer on the beach look at
this
what'd you think of it it's no less than
what we deserve to be honest
[Music]
we're at the beach now Lavi Jack and Liv
are going to surf I'm just going to
chill because I'm Ill and I don't want
to get more ill by going into the cold
water
what's up
[Music]
we're now going to Tesco to get some
food for for the dinner
we're going to have our first dinner
ever in this villa which is very
exciting
[Music]
that is cool isn't it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just going to pretend that I'm not
aware that you're filming just in the
library sometimes like today I try to do
some stuff and I was just like no
we'll get past men for free on the
hospital Library Circle
[Music]
I'm doing very well probably the best
I've ever done please be releasing
activity
[Music]
but
I've just realized I forgot to bring the
head of my toothbrush forgot the tip the
actual brush
I'm ready for bed now first thing
tomorrow morning I will do my CBD and
then I'll go to the corner shop and get
a proper toothbrush but good night
[Music]
[Music]
butterflies
[Music]
[Music]
all right
done with the day and now we're going
back into the village I'm excited I'm so
excited to studying me too for next
week's exam
[Music]
hi peep
how was your morning in Botox Clinic
part of the neurology placement we were
injecting Botox into people who had
strokes and reducing the spasticity in
their arms very interesting morning we
saw a lot of good clinical signs like
clonus oh wow that's actually
interesting
[Music]
don't you never do any of the master
classes or anything I only use fastness
have you done CBD I have this morning it
was so much more relaxed now we just had
it on then it comes through there wow
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we haven't picked that up okay
[Music]
we just got out of sauna and I had a
outdoor shower as well which felt such a
luxury Bobby's looking at me right now
[Music]
we watched an episode of a Netflix
series now we're gonna go to sleep and
tomorrow is going to be the work day
study day because we had our fun today
like with sauna and hot tubs so tomorrow
is the day to study for our upcoming
exam
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
holiday which also allows me to study
and also experience this
one is
a dedication to the news of Krypton in
migraine
history
I can see that
I'm not really sure
which one let's choose one okay go ahead
what why
I know do you know how I remember it I
don't know how you remember it because
it's so final yurias has like a big O in
it overweight so it makes you gain
weight it's very interesting how you
remember things so if it's up and out it
means that
no it's a basically
[Applause]
so basically
so basically
so basically
yeah
now we came to this cute Cafe we had to
walk Against the Wind my hair feels like
it's knotted we're gonna get some food
now should be good
thank you
[Music]
I think it was that bad
hey Siri play
Umbrella by Rihanna here's Umbrella by
Rihanna
[Music]
how's my head guys and my eyebrows
do you guys have any plans for your
final nights in the living villa we're
gonna just have dinner together and play
some games in the hot tub one more time
oh yeah me too and sauna properly yeah
so we can like sweat it off now and then
shower after
[Music]
I'll see if she gets everything
[Music]
queen king Ace
[Music]
I just heard the most relaxing shower
because the showers here are so
luxurious and now we're going to watch a
couple more episodes of the Netflix
series that we started with Lobby last
night and I'm going to sort this hair
out because it's still knotted from the
wind
foreign
[Music]
today we'll be checking out from this
Airbnb at 10 A.M but I realized that
there are still some parts of this house
I haven't used to make the most of this
house I want to use the gaming room and
the gym downstairs and the outdoor stuff
as well football pitch and the hammock
afterwards we'll need to go to hospital
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]